I have made close to $10,000 since November of last year doing data annotation
after I put my kids to bed at night and on the weekends
and this video is going to be
everything you could possibly want or need to know about data annotation
in one spot as clearly and concisely as possible
in this video I'm gonna go over what data imitation is
how to get started
tips and tricks for the assessment
pay in taxes
and then some frequently asked questions before I get too far into it
I'm Chelsea I share remote work positions
side hustles at work and ways to make money from home
so if those are things that interest you
just hit that follow button
and if you could like and save this video
engage with it as much as possible
share it with anybody who you think it might be important to
those things are hugely helpful to me as a creator
let's get into it
what is data annotation
there is a lot of nuance to it
but the too long didn't read version is very simply testing
training and evaluating AI chat bots
how do we get started
so there are a ton of data annotation platforms
there is Remo tasks
AI tasks click works just to name a few
the platform that I personally use
and all of the information that's within this video
is going to be about data annotation
dot tech the assessment
so once you've completed the application portion
you will be pushed onto another page
where you are given the option to take two assessments
one assessment is going to be the core assessment
and if you complete that one and are brought on
your jobs will start at $20 an hour
there's also going to be a coding assessment
if you know how to code
those jobs will start at $40 an hour for you
the the
assessment is an incredible representation
of the work that you will be required to do on the platform
so if you don't like the test
or you think the test is incredibly hard or tedious
you should stop right there and don't waste your time
because you are not going to enjoy the work and you won't be successful in it
here are my assessment tips
I'm gonna keep this really short and sweet
I did do a longer video on this if you are interested in looking at that
but I think these are the most important points
so first and foremost
every single question has an answer and it is available to you on the internet
some might take more digging than others
but you will be able to find an answer to every single question
if you dig enough
on the internet
in the same vein as that
use Google for every single question
even if you think you know it
just use Google
double check all of your answers
your grammar and your spelling
make sure you're paying attention to every single detail
they provide to you in the prompts
everything is relevant
and that's it for my tips on the assessment
let's talk pay and taxes
so on this platform
you're going to be responsible for recording and submitting your time
after seven days they will approve and release those funds to you
you will be required to have a Paypal account
because when they release the funds to you
they will send them to a Paypal account
where you can then transfer them to your bank
Paypal will provide you with a 1099 at the end of the year for taxes
as a 1099 contractor
you will not pay taxes as you're compensated
you will be required to reconcile your taxes next year during tax season
you do have the option as a 1099 contract
an employee to pay estimated taxes quarterly
I'm not a tax professional and I'm not a financial advisor
but I will tell you what I do personally
I save 30% of all of my income and I put that into a high yield savings account
then next year come April when I pay my tax Bill
I will have that money set off to the side
and hopefully
some of the interest that I've earned will just be a little extra for me
so lastly I'm just gonna answer some questions that I've seen really frequently
and the first one is
do you need a computer or can you use an iPad or a phone
I would say you can probably use your phone to take the assessment
but after that it's going to be really
really challenging to do the work on your phone
you might be able to use an iPad if you have an external keyboard
I personally use a 15 inch laptop
and there are times that I find
I don't even have enough room on my screen
to see all of the things that I wanna see at the same time
so no to a phone
maybe to an iPad
definitely to a computer
probably the most popular question is how long does it take to get a response
I heard back within a week
recently I've been hearing from people that it's taken anywhere from four days
to upwards of two weeks
that is probably the biggest complaint about the company
that I do data annotation with
and it is just the fact that they don't let you know if you're not accepted
they only tell people if they're approved
and the last question I'm gonna answer is do they train you
there is an onboarding where you do
sort of like a qualification that teaches you how to use the platform
and then within every project there are explicit instructions
and several of the projects that I've started working on
they bring you into team chats so you can see what other people are doing
you have can ask questions from other workers or admins
things of that nature so you won't be lost
there is a lot more guidance obviously than on the assessment
but a formal training no
I hope that clears up any questions you might have had about data annotation
let me know your experience if you've done it
or if you're going to try it in the comments bye